why is the moon so big actually it's all
on your head
what hey crazy have you ever looked at
the moon when it's really low in the sky
it has better reddish orange color and
it looks so much bigger the color is a
real effect caused by the Earth's
atmosphere the light has to pass through
more air near the horizon and air
scatters away the blue half of the
spectrum the same thing happens with the
Sun at sunrise and sunset but the
hugeness of the Moon is a complete
illusion no for real
it's all in your head it's called the
moon illusion and it's fascinated humans
for a very long time to the timeline the
earliest record we have of the illusion
is from a Tenaya formed tablet that's
been dated to the time of King
Ashurbanipal in ancient Mesopotamia
that's modern-day Iraq Syria and Turkey
but like a long time ago we also have a
record from ancient China during the
time of Confucius back then though
people were convinced it was a real
affect they thought the moon must be
physically closer or the optics of the
atmosphere must enlarge the image even
Aristotle in ancient Greece was
convinced it was optical and we all know
how his ideas turned out it wasn't until
about 1021 seee that someone finally
questioned Abu Ali Al Hasan even Al
Hasan even a - pioneered the concept of
experimentation over 600 years before
Galileo making him one of the first
actual scientist he suggested optics
weren't quite enough to explain the moon
illusion why can't it be a real thing
because the moon's distance from us
doesn't change very much we saw in a
previous video that the moon is this far
away from the earth and because it's so
far away any changes in that distance
will go mostly unnoticed yes the moon's
orbit is elliptical but drawing it like
this is misleading it's more like this
it's almost circular that means over the
course of a month the moon's distance
changes this much it's not that much so
anytime the news or your friends are
like once on its a super moon it's
actually not that big of a deal
there is nothing super about it to make
matters worse the moon looks bigger on
the horizon where it's actually farther
away this is the line you look along
when the moon is high in the sky
but this is the line you look along when
the moon is near the horizon that's an
entire earth radius farther that alone
easily cancels out anything happening in
the atmosphere so what's really going on
there are actually several different
explanations psychologists treat them
like they're competing explanations but
for reasons all they clear later I think
it's all of them at the same time let's
do this first my personal favorite the
Ebbinghaus illusion your brain actually
changes the sizes of things to add
contrast take a look at the orange
circles in this picture the one
surrounded by tiny blue circles looks
bigger but if you remove the blue
circles you can see they're the same
size even now that you know they're the
same size you still probably see them
differently in fact if I animate one you
see the orange circle change size even
though it doesn't actually change the
idea is a similar thing happened to the
moon when it's near the horizon as the
moon rises you have a bunch of buildings
and trees to compare it to so your brain
is all like wow that's really big but
then when it gets higher it's surrounded
only by the vast emptiness of the night
sky so it looks smaller
if you remove everything else from view
by say looking through a paper towel
roll or even just looking at everything
upside down then the moon illusion is
lessened for some people and completely
eliminated for others but since it's not
eliminated for everyone we need more
explanation the second possible
explanation is the Ponzo illusion this
is something we refer to as size
constancy basically our brain knows that
things don't just randomly change size
so as we see something like a person
gets smaller our brains just interpret
that as those a person is moving farther
away the flipside is that if something
looks like it's getting farther away but
doesn't change size then it must be
growing so the idea here is that if we
have the same kind of receding
perspective with the sky that we do with
the ground this could also happen with
the moon when the moon is near the
horizon it must be farther away but it's
always the same size so your brain sinks
it's bigger and it changes your
perception accordingly the problem is
very few people actually say the moon
looks farther away at the horizon most
people say it looks closer finally we
have the SkyDome model
like the puns of illusion which assumes
a flat sky the SkyDome model assumes a
curved sky above a flat ground it
suggests that maybe our brains map all
the really far stuff like stars and the
moon on to an imaginary dome over our
heads the advantage here is that it says
we connect the ground to the sky at the
horizon and as a result underestimate
distances to sky objects we saw in the
other video that at best we can see
about three miles in any direction along
the ground that puts the ground horizon
in this picture about three miles away
so our brains assume the distant clouds
in the sky are also three miles away
when the clouds are actually about ten
miles away a huge underestimate the
thing is though that none of these are
dramatic enough to single-handedly
explain the moon illusion but if we
consider all three at the same time we
might have something the moon illusion
is subtle for some and dramatic for
others a small fraction of people don't
even see it
maybe that's because not everyone is
affected the same way by these someone
who is greatly affected by all of them
like saying my mom is going to just be
mind blown by the size of the moon every
time so how affected are you by the moon
illusion please share in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay for you a little
crazy in the last video we learned what
was outside the universe comment
response time will can't quickscope
asked what aspects of the universe will
finite as I said in the last couple of
videos I would hope all of them
including space general opinion among
cosmologists though is that space is
infinite but all they really know is
that the entire universe is at least
twenty times bigger than the observable
universe regardless let's say space is
infinite time doesn't appear to be there
does appear to be a beginning to the
universe at least the universe as we
know it in time as we know it it began
13.8 billion years ago about 380,000
years after this light was emitted
speaking of which several people asked
why this was an oval and not a circle
it's a map projection of the distant
universe the entire inside of the cosmic
horizon sphere flattened into a plane
it's oval for the same reason this map
of the earth is open
Bobby Harper asked what aliens would see
if they lived in the edge of the
universe
no ash the universe is either in Finnish
or it curves back on itself those are
your only two options the universe
doesn't have any edge but if you mean
the edge of our observable universe they
would just see their own observable
universe around themselves technically
everyone has their own observable
universe around we're just all a little
too close together to notice it it was
too thin sticks wonders what the
difference is between nothing and empty
space empty space is just a space and
time devoid of matter nothingness is a
complete lack of even space or time
literally nothing
gauge widely pointed out the number
files in a video about how far you had
to travel to certain sea copies of
things spoiler alert it's a long way
Jonathan speaking wants more camera-shy
clone he's adorable isn't he I'll see
what I can do and for the last order of
it
YouTube is discontinuing normal
annotations on May 2nd this year which
means we're stuck with that 20-second
mobile n screen so we're now forced to
separate the comment responses into
their own video that last video was a
trial run as a response seemed pretty
positive this video we're back to the
old end stream one last time because I
felt like you all deserved warning ah
change look I don't like change either
but maybe I'll get to respond to more
comic are these more detailed responses
to the same number of come anyway crazy
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]
what a beautiful room tonight that's no
moon that's a Space Station